oh right hmm hey folks hope everyone's
doing alright we got a much more
manageable crap this time that's good to
know
I got too much window going on here
there we go
I was kind of blowing out the background
a little bit that's slightly better I'll
take it uh so if everybody's doing okay
as I said much more manageable crowd
this time because I'm not talking about
YouTube drama or sitting in the tub uh
have you started reading accession yet
no I have not
I have other Commission's that came in
before that including a book that came
in before that that I need to I'm work I
get to it I have not started reading it
yet and one of the things that does not
come with the Commission is a promise of
a timeline I'm hoping to get caught up
on those I'm actually gonna be talking a
little bit about that but no I have not
started yet
hufflepuff from Cornwall sorry I'm early
no traffic in the vortex very nice so I
hope everybody's doing okay
now for the record I am actually
legitimately drinking water this time I
feel like maybe partially because I had
a couple of drunk reviews go up I'm
coming across as way more of a wash then
I actually am so even though it's Cinco
DeMayo I don't have margarita mix and I
don't have tequila and besides which I
think that'd be a little bit I don't
know cringy I'm not sure that it's for
me anyway
as Jim from Friday night dinner says
hello to you all
sure really excited about your Missy
one review actually it's this month so
it's not next month one of the stories
is written by Neve fountain my favorite
Doctor Who writer oh very cool
happy Cinco de Mayo it always happens it
also happens to be my almost birthday so
my family will have Mexican takeout
tonight that's cool let's see how long
it takes a stream to turn into a Doctor
Who QA Oh it'll happen quick it always
does
highest-ranked Doctor Who episode on
IMDB is blink deep yeah ok I don't pay
attention to INTP ratings I oh I hope
that's that wasn't intended to make a
point cuz I'm just kind of shrug Agoge
yeah ok
have you seen Gotham I have an entire
playlist of Gotham reviews and videos
Zuka after the live streams over go look
about the channel uh it's Conners for
angels birthday
oh wait that's that's a day that will
live in infamy although I don't like I
don't dislike Connor nearly as much as
everybody else seems to favorite British
show besides Doctor Who um geez Oh red
dwarf might be my nostalgic favorite Oh
maybe Monty Python though I don't know
it's separating over patreon okay like
separating from a partner communicating
over the messenger future patreon is
that what you mean that's what that's
what my brain thought that sentence
meant but that feels like it makes no
sense
um anyways so I keep gearing up to say
stuff I just watched the Buffy episode
the body Jesus yeah yeah that yeah
that's a rough life okay I just stopped
looking a chat and actually started
talking about one of the things I wanted
to talk about so obviously I've got
channel plans as part of the live stream
description and I know for a lot of
folks that's like a big red flag of oh
my god
what's gonna happen you've burned out
its
the world is ending it no no so this is
stuff that I've actually already sort of
gone over what my plan and intention is
with my patreon supporters last week and
this is me sort of bringing everyone
else up to speed so that it's not a
instant switch over to the world is that
well yes the world is ending but not not
my channel so the first thing is if you
enjoy what I do here and you are not
also subscribed to breakroom of geeks
you really need to do that because that
channel is gonna hit its threshold to
become monetizable this month which
means that starting next month a fair
amount of content that used to be here
is going to go there so here's the
general thinking behind what I'm doing
um well first of all brilliant breakroom
of geeks if you didn't already know is
basically just a less formal very
laid-back you know unscripted reviews
which I also still kind of do here but
it it's it's also be talking about stuff
that wouldn't necessarily catch a lot of
traction here it's basically my place to
be able to talk about things or if I
tried to talk about them here the views
would be so low that it would actually
damage the channel so I can't but that's
a place for me to do those so like I've
been talking about Westworld I've been
talking about movies that I've been
watching with my partner Liz during
quarantine cuz will queue up the same
movie and watch at the same time and
text each other
while it goes on and so we've we've
watched things like warm bodies and love
Simon and stuff like that
it's I did reviews for our Red Dwarf
series 1112 so like stuff stuff that is
still you largely in the wheelhouse of
this channel but just for one reason
or another I I don't I don't feel I'm
belong is necessarily on the main
channel that's what it is now now more
stuff is gonna start migrating over
there
Oh check my mic connect our people
hearing me okay so I got a request to
check the mic connection that's a that's
an issue
cuz the mics not a separate thing yes
loud and clear fine here I can yeah okay
whoo all right give me a heart attack
there there's extra mic noises I'm not
sure why that would be Wow
my just honestly because my laptop is
very loud anyways so bit crackly yeah
it's probably because my laptop so dang
loud I don't know does that help at all
of course now I have to look down here
too I don't know I don't know we got a
power through um anyways so once the
break room of geeks becomes monetizable
which as I said is gonna happen this
month that means that I'm going to be
doing fewer videos on this channel per
month I'm basically gonna cut it down
from four a week to two a week now
that's not to say that I will not
produce comparable amounts of content
just that it's not all gonna be here so
my vision for this is for counseling
geeks to basically become the premier um
content that I do stuff that involves a
little bit more editing maybe some
scripting making just in it's more
planets more thought-out it's something
that that I feel like I have something
more of substance to say that's what's
gonna come and be on here the one thing
that is going to remain kind of rambling
unscripted that will stay on counsel
geeks is going to be the overdue Doctor
Who reviews
that'll still be Wednesday thou continue
through until until I and till I'm reek
ought up and every watch
hold anything so that will stay but
otherwise and I don't know what day it's
gonna be on um I mean Monday our Fridays
my gut instinct I don't know I'll figure
that out later but it'll be that and one
other thing per week so that I have more
time to work on these videos and produce
stuff that I I can do stuff that's a
little bit more ambitious cuz I've had
ideas that are bigger then I can pull
off cranking out four videos a week now
as I said they'll still be a regular
outflow of content but things like
trailer reactions where I mean uh you
know actually just trailer reactions
that'll be breakroom
trailer reviews where I don't feel like
I have a ton to say just beyond oh looks
interesting if I don't have something
substance and to dig up that'll go over
there most movie reviews will go over
there most commissioned reviews will
migrate over to the break room and so
there will be fewer videos here
specifically I'm not changing the kinds
of things I'm going to talk about and I
you know it's I'm not come I'm not I'm
not starting from zero I'm not trying to
read redesign the wheel here but I am
trying to give myself fewer things that
I'm trying to do at once so I can do
those things as bigger and hopefully
better so that's sort of the main thing
to talk about in terms of channel plans
is there will be fewer videos per week
on here but if you are also subscribed
to break room of geeks
you'll probably get close to the same
amount of content the other thing about
the break room of geeks is there's no
schedule on that that's just videos go
up as I do them because those are really
quick turnaround because I do virtually
no editing on those so you know but it's
not a fixed this day this day this day
the way it currently is on council of
geeks so that's the first thing that I
wanted to sort of talk to everybody
LGBT stuff I hope stays monthly um yeah
I am not planning to drop lgbtq+ content
it is my hope to continue to do that
monthly I'm not gonna make an absolute
promise to that because if I feel like I
don't have a topic that I got enough to
work with I may go a month without but
like that's always gonna be something I
come back to and it is my goal to do
that monthly I'm just not gonna make
that an absolute promise your review of
Joker you said it was deliberately
trying to cause a fence sorry but I just
don't see how it was I I'm with all due
respect I am NOT gonna revisit that
right now on the chat I have no interest
in talking about that movie
my half-brother turned five oh whoa
happy birthday to him the zombie
apocalypse was to happen what would you
do I would collect my daughter her
mother and my partner and get to the
highest building that we could because
you can disable the elevators and then
the stairwell is a choke point and
really easy to barricade so that's
always been my plan of course that's a
tough gig depending on how long things
dragged on because you'd have to go out
scrounging for supplies and lug them up
the stairs but you know you pick your
battles it helps the drama with Blair is
making me do more research on chin
transgenderism and gender dysphoria
still want to buy your book oh thank you
Ben yeah that whole thing I don't oh boy
I don't want to get it I definitely
don't want to get into that fresh again
I've said my piece on it at this point
but that what's what's annoying about
that is I know it's going to keep
popping up like I I've said my piece and
response to it and I wish that I could
then basically choose and now the world
is done talking about it but I I don't
the power to do that so I still get
intermittent comments you know thrown at
me that were very clearly came from
people who saw our video and things like
that and that'll continue to happen for
a while but like I said before it's not
it's not the avalanche of abuse that
happened a couple years ago when barring
feature two video of mine so you know I
know it can be worse
but just the fact that it'll it'll crop
up every now and then is just
frustrating I thought I thought you
would say collect them all and get to
the Winchester just wait for this whole
thing to blow over
I showed my parents Jojo rabbit my dad
said I don't think anything bad will
happen just as Jojo was following the
butterfly oh no oh no oh oh that hurt my
soul just to read that if you've seen
Jojo rabbit thing you know why oh dang
Wow who would win in a fight Malcolm
Tucker or the twelfth doctor well one of
them can regenerate and has a sonic
screwdriver and the power of time travel
the others just very sweary I don't
think that's actually that much of a
fight
you're asking who would win in a debate
that's a tougher call but like a fight
the doctor obviously Captain Jack our
River Song um if you're asking me in
terms of characters overall I'm gonna
say Jack just because I'm more open to
Jack coming backwards I feel like I
don't I'm done with the river and I like
river quite a bit but I I don't need her
to come back
worries I'd be very happy to AB Jack
come back
twelves punched through a wall a hundred
times stronger than diamond yeah he
would wait wait he did but it took him
two to billion years so let's not let's
not put too much weight into those
punches and thus the doctor who QA has
begun you started it
it's possible to do it yeah yes
and it is possible to commission a game
playthrough I actually have been
commissioned to do what it's I depending
on what the game is I can't promise that
I can do it as a let's play cuz I don't
have the ability to capture footage from
some things that I have but I do have
one that has been commissioned and I am
working on and will hopefully really
start to to dig into soon no you start
up yeah I probably did what do you want
to happen if there's a thirteen in Jack
reunion scene I have no idea I just want
to see it people ask me what do you want
to happen if X like I almost never have
specific expectations tied to like
characters meeting or what have you
because I want to see what the writers
do I want to see what the actors do I
don't want to come in thinking it should
be this Oh show me what show me what you
want to do now if it doesn't work I
might in my head go I wish they'd done
this instead I want to I'm I can't
pronounce the guy's name
we gotta blame Jamie Lannister has the
doctor um and for those of you who don't
know please Jaime Lannister I know he's
not British but do you think he'd be
good um
see like I really do have a mental block
in my head about it being somebody
British and the thing is I I'm sure he
would I'm sure he'd be fine but like
nothing that makes me go ooh I want that
enough to to go with a non British
doctor
everyone loves knives out and I do
except I was on a date when watching it
and fell asleep oh dear I will defend
class until the end I still haven't seen
class that's fallen so far back it's
become one of those things that
somebody's probably gonna have to
commission to meter me to review it if
they actually care to hear what I think
witch doctor and companion that I've
never met do you think would work best
together I would love to see 12in Jamie
McCrimmon I would love that me and my
brother figured out an alternative to
the timeless trial for God's sake this
thing will never die huh the timeless
Kyle they discover a regenerating edge
Lord use him drum monster energy through
time Lord's thoughts there's a blog that
says help them was a subversion of lore
arcs do you want me to link so you can
address it in the review no no because I
never want my reviews to ever become me
debunking somebody else's interpretation
like if something is if there's
something that I know is the popular
consensus that I disagree with I'll
address that but no I have I have
absolutely no interest in recounting or
debunking somebody else's pet theory
they can have their pet theory good on
them I'm not even saying I wouldn't be
opening to read it but like even if I do
I'm not gonna address it in a review
that's that's not happening Scott
Pilgrim vs. the world something you're
into well I never in the books the
comics I saw the movie I liked it a lot
the first time I saw it the more I think
about it the more problems I have with
it
it's incredibly well presented
it's an insanely well-made movie trying
to do something that's nuts and doing a
very good job of it but there are things
about it them just like my big thing is
honestly those two should not have ended
up together at the end
but that no they just shouldn't and I
don't mean like Scotch of the loss I
mean they should have realized hey we
this actually probably isn't healthy for
either of us and maybe we should both
learn to be single for a while like if
you want to leave the the possibility
open though they get together later fine
but I don't like that they end up
together at the end like at all
especially because Scott's kind of a
terrible person do you think the cyber
masters are the hybrid that one thing
from series 9 no the God bringing hybrid
huh this really does exemplify how badly
that entire series arc was resolved
because people are are trying to say
that part of the timeless child was
tying up the hybrid as a dropped
plotline but it wasn't a drama plotline
it was dealt with in hell bent badly and
in a way that makes no almost no sense
but it was done now realize at this
point I am working from memory so I have
not rewatched hell-bent in a while but
if I am remembering correctly the what
the hybrid ends up being is basically
the 12th is Capaldi's doctor and Clara
combined because the two of them are
effectively a whole person because she
has become so intertwined in his
timeline that he basically only exists
because of her and she is practically
his other half that is the reason that
he goes to such extreme
lengths to bring her back from the dead
which is something he's never done for
any other companion so the hybrid is not
a singular being it is a composite of
him and Clara effectively operating as a
single entity even though they are
technically separate people it's stupid
it's poorly communicated but it was not
a dropped plotline it was there it was
just back are you gonna re-watch how
bends on your take two reviews I am the
thing is that'll actually be a take
three on because I have two videos about
that already
play my first ever game of D&D over
Skype got to admit I'm disappointed I'm
sorry to hear that I've never tried
doing tabletop role-playing over Skype I
would imagine it loses a bit of the
flavor especially if you don't already
have a rapport with with the gaming
group thanks for that explanation of the
hybrid never could figure out what that
was about
hell-bent was a stupid and ruin cars
death I wanted her to step into her
death again yeah I kind of wish that
they like set it up so that she could
theoretically return later or even ever
own spin-off but given that that never
they never did anything with that I
really wish that they had done that as
well I'm super excited to see it oh boy
uh I have not really watched that it was
a very long time what's your favorite
song from the 90s
um goodness I said I'm not even sure off
atop my head constantinople by it by
They Might Be Giants
and games stole the porter's portal
scene from king fury i oh okay I don't
know quick I don't know what king fury
is that doesn't doesn't mean a ton to me
made it here better late than never
welcome cappuccino They Might Be Giants
as timeless no pun intended
oh it's funny no matter what I intend
the conversation to be eventually it
will always be Doctor Who unless I
actually put in this fat that I am NOT
doing Doctor Who which I have had to do
sometimes when I was not in the mood to
talk of a puppet um fair but if you
don't address it you'll get a comment
from a guy saying your video is wrong
and you're an idiot or something I argue
with that guy for a whole night well
first of all don't engage with those
people and you you act you act as if
kung fury I still don't know what that
is you act as if people saying you're an
idiot and you're wrong is something that
I should avoid and would happen if I
could like that happens nearly every
video repeatedly like I'm not worried
about somebody coming in and trying to
argue with me my advice to you is to not
engage you'll notice I usually don't
reply to those comments do you enjoy
watching or playing any sports is our
tree a sport cuz I do that watch I've
never enjoyed watching sports ever I
find I I'm not saying I don't get the
appeal but what is appealing about
sports has zero appeal to me
III I know people can like sort of build
a narrative out of watching a team or a
specific player for a season or a career
and but like I'm interested in stories
that are crafted deliberately that's
what I enjoy
a a sports game has one of two outcomes
this side wins or this side wins and the
only way to get more than that out of it
is to really dive deep and have a
serious investment in these teams or
these players and I don't want to do
that to Shea if you could give the
advice to me from last week that would
be swell
I'll hop in the TARDIS and take care of
that typically Doctor Who episodes set
the future trend to be better than MPUs
say oh sorry set in the future tend to
be better better than episode set in the
past why do you think it is well part of
it is that setting anything in the past
is inherently more restrictive because
you are obliged to do some degree of
research and to keep things within some
confines of a reality of the past as we
know it now that's not to say that all
episodes set in the past are bad some of
them are great but by setting something
in the past you have inherently put more
limitations on what it can be and what
it can do then anything set on another
planet or in the future so I think
that's that's the inherent problem that
probably leads to the trend Sherlock
will be turning 10 this year do you have
any plans to make a video commemorating
this anniversary or not um no um what I
might do will we'll see if I if I get to
this point or not what I might do is if
I feel the need to re-watch sure because
I only have reviews up for the last
series of that series before so if I
felt like going back and re watching the
previous ones I might do videos in the
break room for that no promises but it's
it's possible
is it acceptable for character to come
out as gay following the bear death if
they were a very private person and
that's probably the most natural way
that could have come out um I need more
context than that to make my own
personal and it would only be my own
personal call it as to whether I feel
that that would work or be appropriate
depending on the kind of character
you're creating there are definitely
some characters who have who are just
playing things way closer to the vest
and are not going to be is open and
maybe they're friends or companions
don't learn much more about them after
they've died and they're doing things
like going through effects or packing up
their their old house or something so
that's that's certainly viable as an
option whether it's the only option or
the most natural one that's gonna depend
on the rest of the context that I don't
know are you after the changes to the
channel for Matt not a who tuber anymore
I don't mind either way just wondering
well I mean I don't know because I I
didn't find this community you found me
so it's funny because like the first
time I turned off on something like the
top 50 who tubers I didn't even know I
was on there I found out to you after
and then I went back I'm like was I in
the year before oh hey look at that
so I mean like I'm not gonna stop
talking about Doctor Who like I said the
overdue Doctor Who reviews are still
gonna be on the council of geeks Channel
and cap and Doctor Who is still gonna be
a regular topic of conversation
I've still got lists of related to
Doctor Who that I want to do there are
some episodes or plots or other things
that I would like to do deeper dives
into that I currently have um so Doctor
Who contents not gonna go away whether
or not people will still consider me a
who tuber if it's no longer making up
the majority of my output I don't know
that's a call other people
I'm just gonna do what I'm gonna do I
came in late so someone probably already
asked when is the Cold War review coming
tomorrow because tomorrow is Wednesday
and Wednesday is overdue Doctor Who have
you watched the Harlequin animated show
I have not that one I haven't found the
time cliche I know but do you ship any
character in the Doctor Who universe um
no not who aren't already together so
like I can't say that I ship vastra and
Jenny cuz they're already a couple
they're adorable and I love it I'm not a
shipper most of the time I'm not gonna
say it never happens but it's pretty
uncommon for me I recently saw your
Sandman si so now I'm curious thoughts
on the Real Ghostbusters episode of the
grundle um I haven't I've only watched
that one in a while that was not one of
my favorites it's pretty good it's
decent it's solid um I don't love it
though if I was ever gonna do another
focus on Real Ghostbusters episode which
is unlikely because the the views on
that one for how much work it took to
put it together the that equation
doesn't balance but if I was ever gonna
talk about specific episodes again I
probably either talk about when
Halloween was forever or citizen ghosts
cuz those are the other ones that are
way up there for me on the I suppose on
the slight backburner would be mrs.
Rogers neighborhood or I don't know why
I like this one so much the devil to pay
I like that one a lot too that one I
think is just straight-up nostalgia
when will you be releasing than the
thing you look up the fans deserve it I
will I as soon as I can get a cut see I
like to your thing and did something
else with it was that clever I don't
think so I think that was that was dad
joke levels that's I mean I'm a father
so I guess uh HC Sacha diwan's master
yay or nay I'm enjoying him uh what was
it like meeting John Barrowman I need to
know it was great
he's wonderful he is he is a he is an
effervescent glowing human being he's
wonderful he's a joy the guy was very
quiet didn't appear in the book was much
and had a power that Ariel was terrified
of that they were stuck with so antenna
to stay away from most people okay well
that kind of context that makes sense
Disney is making a six prior to the
Caribbean thought oh please tell me
they're not bringing Johnny Depp back
again like there might be some mileage
left in that franchise but not in that
character they need to let him just be
done we're getting another Green Hornet
reboot for some reason we're getting it
for some reason because established
properties are considered to be more
valuable council of geeks is uncut
confirmed accurate also in that same
series the main character came out as by
this gender-fluid character so series
pretty decent what series is this that
we're talking about we're cuz we're
having a conversation about LGBTQ
people's characters of the series and if
you mentioned what it was I missed it
dad jokes are always good no dad jokes
are never good that's why they're great
greetings did you hear Taika Waititi is
directing the next Star Wars movie my
favorite director and Robert Rodriguez
is directing a Mandalorian
episode um Robert Rodriguez I had heard
I think I'd heard Taika Waititi had been
assigned to it but until we have a title
and a plan I'm not gonna I don't have
any thoughts because in my mind that's
right up there with you know the fact
that Ryan Johnson was supposed to get a
trilogy separate from the main saga yeah
it's very easier you know before that
you know Josh Trank was gonna make a
boat with that movie or whatever
happened to the obi-wan thing that was
gonna be a movie and then it was gonna
be show and then it was like nothing
there is that but the frequency with
which Star Wars stuff gets announced is
is too much but like we learn of there
looking into this person or this story
and how frequently that goes nowhere
like and until something actually starts
shooting I kind of view it skeptically
now if it actually happens I'll be
curious to see what his take is would
you ever get kicked awk I actually have
it as an app I don't I am put anything
on it I have an idea for like one thing
but I haven't I haven't taken the time
to do it but but I I have it I first of
all let's just accept I'm Way too old to
be on tech dawg
I shouldn't even know what tick tock is
the fact that I do that's that's mmm I
really am out of the age range of these
things now it's it's only the fact that
I I do so much Internet related content
that I have the slightest clue that any
of these things are and most of them
scare me cuz I am old
the Harley Quinn animation show is my
favorite show
I wish they'd let me pay for legit uh
pardon me for the terrible pun but I
think the Pirates franchise has more or
less sunk
skulduggery pleasant is the series okay
cool
which area of lgbtq+ do you think has
the least representation um I suppose it
depends how finely you want to slice it
because there there are letters there
that you can subdivide so like not to
reopen a can of worms but the T for
trans is meant to be something of an
umbrella term for anyone who has an
identity that does not match the gender
that they were assigned at birth now if
you're gonna lump everybody under trans
there is an increasing amount of
representation but if you're gonna
subdivide and make it super specific
trans women have more representation
than trans men non-binary trans have
very little representation and then you
get into things like very specific
slivers of non-binary things like you
know by gender a gender oh and all sorts
of very finely tuned variants so you
could you can find elements of lgbtq+
that have next to no representation but
again it depends on how specifically
you're gonna drill it down at a guest's
i would say a sexual and/or a romantic
and I say and/or because they are not
the same thing but they are related that
probably has the least canonical
representation that's one of those areas
where you get a lot of headcanon
asexuals or a romantics but very few
confirmed so that that's probably would
be my call as off about my head having
done no extensive research what was one
thing that terrified you as a child for
me it was the idea of a potential
the apocalypse I didn't have a lot of
deep-rooted fears as a kid I had like
panicky fears I don't like bugs
I still don't like bugs um but that's
like good yeah I don't have fears that I
like sit awake and worry about I ain't
really as a kid either
so I don't really have an answer for
that
I actually really hope they make another
Pirates of the Caribbean movie with Jack
Sparrow Oh gets slaughtered so hard that
would be a candidate for a drunk review
who would have the better wedding
bachelor and Jenny Sherlock and Watson
or Crowley in a zero
o'kroley in a zero would have the most
amazing just absolutely bonkers nonsense
wedding ever
it would be incredible plans to do any
reviews on Brooklyn nine-nine
um not anything like an episode or even
a season review um if and when I
eventually get caught up Oh
maybe like some character dissections or
something but that not be about it he's
directing until he pisses off Kathleen
Kennedy well I think that's the that's
the assumption with everybody everybody
hired to direct a Star Wars movie you're
here until until somebody at the table
gets annoyed with you wait until your
daughter gets older or you'll know more
than you want to re tik-tok and other
teen things - fourteen well the thing is
by the captain - by the time my kids 14
tick tock is gonna be for old people
it'll be a whole new thing oh by the way
how hard was it to get into each
character for the nickname video haha
so only patreon supporters are gonna
know what beat Master's talking about
there um that's a video that's gotta go
up on the break on the break room
tomorrow it was not very hard at all
because there it basically is what goes
on in my head or I've seen it happens
many times that was a lot of fun though
I enjoyed that I think I intersex has
the least amount that's distinctly
possible have you ever seen quantum leap
I've seen like one or two episodes when
I was like 9 but not like really
watching like it was on when I was in
the room
please watch Friday night dinner such an
amazing show I don't I know neither what
it is nor whether I would be interested
in do you watch or listen to John
mulaney's comedy yes I enjoy John
Mulaney quite a bit actually
me and my sister have a rivalry with
Buffy characters I love Drusilla and
faith she hates them she prefers angel
not Angelus and Riley whose side do you
want Riley
captain cardboard Rick look neither
Drusilla or faith are my favorite
characters but Angel and Angel I admire
for his character journey in his arc in
a vacuum I don't love him Angelus is way
more fun
Riley right I'm sorry
I don't get it
no need to address just thanking you as
a nice person oh well you're welcome
we'll be doing classic ooh reviews on
the break room or still be doing them
through audio for right now I'm gonna
keep them as the podcast the only reason
that will change is if I figure out
something else to do as a regular
podcast feature because I don't want to
stop doing the podcast and having the
classic reviews there allows for me to
you know have something to put there
every month so if I ever figured out
something else to do like the like
before I started doing classic Doctor
Who you know it will it
that podcast feed has changed so many
times because initially it was longer
versions of things that were up on video
forum and that was nine these comics
retrial and then it was going home
Hollywood you're drunk and then it was
see space cowboy and now it's overdue
classic Doctor Who review if I figure
out something else that I want to do as
a as a regular thing that would take up
some time then maybe I'd move the
classic Doctor Who over to the break
room but for right now that's probably
gonna stay where it is
impossible decision Rory pond or rip
hunter see it will be Rory if it comes
packaged with Amy because they really
are a double act
Rory by himself we'll probably get on my
nerves opinions on Billy Eilish she
seems fine it was a really cool
performance um this was when did they do
it Halloween the Halloween burlesque
show this past year the group number for
the Green Mountain cabaret they they had
spliced the upper splice together a
couple of things including bad guy and
it was that was a that was a fun number
I'm always gonna be a sucker for any
song that I associate with a burlesque
number that I like so I don't really
know her work outside that and hearing
her rendition of what was it yesterday
which I liked thought that was good I
don't know if this applies to others but
happened to me and a few of my friend
who viens is that the monster they saw
around the age six or seven terrified
them it was Prisoner Zero for me Oh like
the thing I saw when I was around that
age is scared the crap out of me was the
Skeksis emperor and the Dark Crystal and
the reason they've talked about this
before the reason was the Skeksis
emperor and not any of the others was
the
because he looked so emaciated and sick
like there's there's kind of an inherent
fear for children of illness and age
because they're things that you don't
fully understand but you know you know
are kind of in your future and that that
choking gasping thing is just the
embodiment of sickness and age and it
scared the crap outta me
pretty sure captain cardboard was Grant
Ward's code name and season one of
agents of shield well yeah but he became
awesome
Riley never did top three Buffy villains
um
Angela's spike and I guess glory did you
find time to fit in star kid plays like
you were hoping the fandom is really
active right now I've got I've got
twisted right there I had wanted to get
to it this weekend I didn't I am
by the next time I do a live stream I
really want to have watched because it's
long overdue you'll know if I do because
I'll put a review up on the break room
for my two cents I enjoy seeing your
classic reviews it's like a college
class on Doctor Who that I have a bad
track record of watching I have a hard
time with podcasts I'm fair enough have
you ever seen the live-action Incredible
Hulk TV series from the late 70s early
80s like bits and pieces and long long
time ago so I don't really remember at
this point you have the antidote to a
poison consumed by Giles and Donna who
do you save I punch you in the head for
even asking me to make that decision
ultimately probably Donna but Oh what do
you think of Tim Burton I mean he's
Maura brand now than a director he's
fine he just kind of keeps plugging
along doing his thing trying to remember
the last time I saw a Tim Burton movie I
think I'm not sure I've seen I'm trying
to figure out what was the last one that
came out whether it was his Charlie and
the Chocolate Factory big fish or corpse
bride whatever was the last of those it
was probably the last time I saw it Tim
Burton movie Oh No cuz I saw oh I saw
Alison Wonderland
yeah the scariest aspect of Prisoner
Zero to me was the idea of having him by
hidden behind a door that was hidden in
plain sight for years okay yeah I can
see how that would that would eat away
at you waters of Mars scare me as a kid
I had a fear of being chased and those
things just ran at Pete
could even catch up to david tennant in
his hand shoes vinyls or cassettes I
have no real nostalgia for vinyls I grew
up on cassettes but I'm not actually
gonna go to bat for them because they
degrade with time even if you're not
playing them so vinyl by default I guess
Wicked Witch of the West or princess
mombi scarier oz villainous um well if
we're going I because I've only ever
read an illustrated version of the
original Wonderful Wizard of Oz book um
and I've never read any of the others so
I only know princess mombi from Return
to Oz which I have not seen oh my god I
don't remember what I was young when I
saw that I have not even seen that as an
adult but on the other hand the Wicked
Witch of the West never scared me so I
don't know how to answer that really
glory don't get me wrong I liked her as
a villain but she wasn't my favorite I
mean like that's that's me if I actually
stopped and thought about it for longer
I probably would actually you know what
scribe said it'd be the mayor it was
your favorite David Tennant rolled Tenth
Doctor or curly or kilgrave kilgrave
like kilgrave is terrified and he is a
masterfully constructed villain he's so
good I really hated Adam as a villain
and Buffy see he wasn't well used
discord Thank You Carolyn um I Adam was
not well used but I thought the idea of
him and the performance of him was
interesting his very methodical nature
was very different from other villains
and I really liked the point made by
Buffy Wednes and
he's not afraid that you're going to oh
I don't know kill him and she just goes
no he's really not we're for him like
what he's doing isn't even really about
Buffy he knows she's gonna try and stop
him but he doesn't really care that much
about her one way or the other
I liked him as a shake-up again not
exceptionally well utilized but I
actually guy feel adam is a-- is a
little bit over maligned a person
because season four is a mess have you
seen any of jodi Whittaker's previous
works yes i've seen the first c series
of broadchurch and i've seen the episode
of black marrow that she was in i think
that's it though any shows of movies
you're gonna watch during the lockdown
that you didn't expect to enjoy but then
did um I wasn't trying to remember I
wasn't sure I was going to enjoy the
love Simon I had heard many good things
but it's not my genre I did end up
liking it for the most part with like
one major note but the reviews on in the
breakroom
oh and that's the other thing that'll
probably end up moving is actually these
live streams I will probably move these
to the break room um
once that is monetizable I'll put up you
know reminders and everything on the
community page for council of geeks but
um these will probably move too so
that's another reason if you're not
already subscribed to break room of
geeks you might might want to do that
and soon okay so I gotta hop over the to
the discord real quick let's see
there's a little bit of back and forth
between people more aren't really
questions for me to address hang on um
as a non harry potter fan i'm simply
being curious with the exception of
sniping yourself who are the best
example of good Slytherin characters
Lidl estranged it's what I would go with
for that if you had to lock down with
two Farscape characters Crichton
excluded bad nuts who would they be
um Chiana would definitely be one maybe
Dargo would be the other I feel like I
could get on if Crichton could get on
his good side I think I could get on his
good side yeah I think that's it yep
that's it for the discord we are gonna
be wrapping it up soonish yeah I mean
I'm just gonna jump down to the bottom
I've missed the thoughts on Caleb um you
mean like on West world or or Buffy
because I'm sorry I'm finished watching
West world on Sunday so that's in my
head if you mean um Buffy he was fine
yeah a little on the nose for a villain
for that show what was your most visited
website in high school I don't want
member I wasn't I didn't have I didn't
have online communities in high school
the internet was mostly something it was
the domain of search engines for the
most part when I was in high school you
know Alta Vista and Lycos and Yahoo and
asked Jeeves and all that stuff so you
know stuff for class and just trying to
kill time I didn't have regular sites
that I visited
and when I was in high school
do you miss Murray gold actually no and
that's not a knockout marigold I've come
to enjoy the the new direction on the
music if you had to lock down with one
of the red dwarf crew who would it be
I mean Crichton cuz then I wouldn't have
to do anything I was all about yahoo
chats in 2001 well so was i but I was in
college by then you people forget I'm
not I'm not as young as a lot of you
seem to think I am okay weird idea for
Dario episode what if the doctor or a
campaign got possessed by weird space
demon your opinion possessions stories
don't do a lot for me for the most part
so I mean you it could be well executed
any story idea can be well executed but
that ID doesn't throw me personally shag
marry kill mal Kaylee Jane shag mal
marry Kaylee kill Jane tempted to do
reviews for Rick and Morty no I don't
watch Rick I don't like Rick and Morty I
watched three episodes and I wasn't
having fun
I wasn't enjoy wasn't engaged enough
with the characters to want to come back
I wasn't I could see where it was
intelligent and clever and all the rest
of the things that everyone says about
it but I just didn't care about these
people I didn't want to keep watching
them so no sorry your new break room
reviews of Red Dwarf it may it may have
been going back to an old idea but 20
cos my all-time favorite episode fare
2100 the yahoo group was up and running
in amazing
which Doctor Who celeb interaction was
the best for me probably John Barrowman
but I've also met Matt Smith Peter
Cavalli
um my interactions with most of them
have been very brief I would say
probably John Barrowman let's see we are
gonna wrap up soon I didn't like Rick
and Morty either he was just abrasive of
me and that's kind of my thing like I'm
not saying that you can't do that you
can absolutely do that
just realize I may not want to watch it
mr. fynch or the dream Lord which one
would you rather bring back ooh see my
answers are gonna depend on who the
doctor currently is with the doctor
we've got right now the dream Lord if it
had been Capaldi it would have been mr.
Finch what would happen if 12 met 13 I
have no idea I hope we find out at some
point
eventually I'm guessing you've seen it
what did you think of red dwarf back to
earth red dwarf back to earth is it's in
the pile of things that I call good
execution of a bad idea because it's not
a good idea and I kind of hate the idea
but I don't hate the episode I don't
love it either but the fact that they
took a concept of that I hate and made
something that I'm like no that was
pretty good that's really good execution
of that terrible idea I'm debating
whether I should send you a Funko pop of
either Lockhart or eleven oh I'm running
out of Rome Alicia I'm gonna have to
reel I am actually gonna be reorganizing
my space relatively soon
at least I keep telling myself that
we'll see how that pans out since you
like musical theater ooh and it got away
from me have you seen the producers film
remake guys god the beautiful irony of
John Barrowman and singing
as the same amount in springtime for
Hitler yes I am familiar with that yes
I've seen it and yes I knew that was him
no springtime for Hitler and Germany I
thought the thing you went by he him
pronouns on the counseling geeks channel
III actually at this point I mean
different that used to be my directives
say go with he him here and she her for
for very wild but I at this point I'm
really indifferent on pronouns and my my
go-to thing is say whatever makes the
most sense in your head some people
think of me in more feminine terms and
for them it's more natural to say she
for some people they think of me more
masculine terms and it's more natural
say he either ones fine the only time
I'm home I'm ever gonna take issue is if
I pick up that somebody is deciding on a
pronoun to call me with the intention of
bathing me or trying to piss me off so
if you're using pronouns to be a jerk at
me
I'll take issue with that regardless of
what the pronouns oh but other than that
I really don't I'm not too bothered by
pronouns right now at this point in my
life
why do you dislike love monsters I find
it quite entertaining yeah watch the
overdue Doctor Who review it I did on it
I stand by everything I said there if
you could have any doctor one through
seven will return in full form for the
next anniversary special who which would
you pick to easily yeah I'm gonna start
keeping track of some of these questions
that they come up cuz I swear I answer
them like every time with your ranking
videos will you rank your favorite
Doctor Who story from each season from
best to worst um
I hadn't thought of that maybe with that
song this has just been demonetized will
see possibly might get away with it how
are you I'm just peachy what if for the
six-step it's a musical in each modern
doctor has their own personal song
that's slightly tacky I haven't even
finished the scripts yet but I already
have a theme tune in costumes for a
series I'm making awesome yeah you have
to start somewhere you don't you don't
necessarily have to start with a script
you you're allowed to start with
costumes or locations or character work
not everyone has to start in the same
place have you seen the moon Catherine
Tate sketch with David I saw that it
existed I didn't I didn't see it
directly and I am gonna wrap it up
am i bothered yeah I know um so the I do
find um Oh God
I keep trying to wrap up but you've been
you folks ask questions that I actually
want to answer when watching Gotham did
you ship ed and Oswald no because in my
head Canon Oswald was asexual and
mistook platonic friendship for romantic
interest because he's never had emotions
for anyone other than his mother he
assumed if he felt that strongly it must
be love so in my mind you know yeah it's
like how when you're in high school and
you have your high school relationship
and you're like this is the deepest love
anyone has ever felt but the reason you
think that is cuz you don't have a frame
of reference you don't have enough
experience behind you that's what I
meant for Oswald I think all Walt is
actually asexual but he is so bad at
recognizing positive emotional feelings
that the minute he felt anything
positive towards Ed he assumed love cuz
he had no frame of reference what's your
favorite fashion brand no mm-hmm
whatever's cheap and fits
favorite music genres I I don't know I
really am all over the place
yes ace headcanons yeah see exactly you
should have scheduled overdue Doctor Who
review for the 50th to coincide with the
two-year anniversary of overdue Doctor
Who review that would have been cool but
the thing is like I'm doing them every
week so unless I screw up the order that
I'm doing the minute I can't actually
plan on when they land what's your
favorite movie ghostbusters have you
seen the end of the world I have not
sometimes I like to pretend I'm a carrot
is that normal
you're asking me what's normal I think I
think you have not found an impartial
judge you also think Oswald was a
romantic ah that's a tougher call
possibly I didn't have a firm thing on
that are any of the Ghostbusters sequels
worth watching
no the Real Ghostbusters cartoon is but
the film no okay
that's that's it I do have I do have to
wrap up I'm gonna I'm gonna go eat some
strawberries and and watch a movie I
think right if I could just get on a
couch enough someone lower them into my
mouth that that'd be perfect social
distancing dang it haha just listen to
my first Big Finish is so detailed I
know they're great no question this time
just to say I hope you're having a nice
day it's it's getting better so thank
you what's the worst Disney remake I
don't know because I've only seen one
and it was the one my kid wanted to go
to so I can't answer that cuz I don't
watch them non-binary flags shirt I
don't think it's actually the correct
colors for anything technically
but I don't know anyways so we're gonna
wrap it up thanks everybody for tuning
in stay safe I know that some areas
particularly in the US are starting to
reopen or are looking into it or making
plans to do that
so remember going out it's still in your
best interest and the best interest of
everybody else for you to continue to
wash your hands or mask if you have one
take in the considerations because if we
just act like bars gone and then it gets
real bad again so take care of
yourselves
be safe use your best judgment and okay
don't be doing well there there will be
light at the end of all this and in the
meantime I'll be here doing what I do so
just remember you are beautiful
you're valid you are aloft you're the
council I just run the meetings have a
good night everybody